all the great cures that these morons
have all in one video so how do you
what is your process like are you like
hey here's my idea and then you write it
out i mean how do you make these tick
tocks tell us tell us a little bit about
that
yeah so i'm pretty much like uh i've got
like twitter trending you know kind of
like sitting there in the background to
figure like all right what's what is
being brought up because i don't there's
so much [ __ ] out there that i
i i'll miss it right and i feel like
twitter's a great resource to kind of
like bubble those things to the surface
um
and then from there or or even before
that if i catch something online or i'm
reading an article i'm just like this is
uh
so messed up or this is so extreme or
this is so ridiculous whatever it is
because i think you know over the last
year or
year plus two years three years whatever
uh
uh
satire
and parody like normally you'd be like
yeah i'm gonna hide into like a 10 or
11. but then like when reality has
heightened
already base level to like 10 or 11 then
you've got to like take it beyond
that to like a 15 16 maybe a 20
depending on what you're trying to do to
get the point across
uh it's hard because you're like always
competing with something in the news
that is
you're like that would never happen like
thinking back like i never imagined this
timeline to be this [ __ ] up
uh this crazy and so the process is
really like
seeing what's what's trending online
what people are talking about you know
is there a story that's not really being
talked about in trying to bring
attention to it or
uh reading up for in this case reading
up on stories of
uh of what an anti-vaxxer will take but
or accept the vaccine right and it's
like the other ones are like turpentine
and
uh
uh
oh people that were drinking um hydrogen
peroxide like there's so many it's like
you would literally be like all right
listen here's this safe thing to do
and like no no i don't want to take that
and um
the videos i do try to
try to take a snapshot of those of those
events or those moments and then kind of
write them into a story you know within
a minute 60 seconds or like within 60
seconds or so
so i mean it's a good point because what
you're talking about in a lot of your
videos are like serious
real [ __ ] issues and
some of it is laughable you know it's
easy to mock like you're saying it's
easy to mock but sometimes it's not hard
to mock them because they are saying the
thing
that you are trying to say in the video
but they're saying it the way that you
would say it like it's like you are the
satire what the satire is [ __ ] dead
right right yeah yeah so we had a huge
example of that like back in 2000 uh and
an eight really all the way back then
when john mccain selected sarah palin
and
and they would stand on saturn live she
would stand there and she would just say
the same things that sarah palin said
the night before in an interview and
everyone's like
and it was like that's exactly what she
said almost the same cadence of how she
said it
tina fey is just doing a a really silly
facial expression maybe an
over-exaggerated facial expression and
movements but she's saying almost the
exact same thing in the exact same
cadence that she said it it's it was
alarming
yeah it's pretty it's one of those
things you know like you look at snl and
you're like all right what
what topic you know current event or
trending kind of thing that's being
talked about are they going to
you know mock make fun of or you know
adapt to do a parody or satire whatever
and
yeah back in 2008 you see tina fey doing
literally what you know sarah palin said
then you fast forward to 2020
you know even 2016 too as well you know
they had a lot of mocking stuff between
the debates uh between trump and you
know hillary clinton uh and then you
fast forward to 2020 and it's like
every
i feel like
2020 and everyone was at their home and
was watching everything happen in real
time and everyone did have the question
of like is this real life is this satire
i don't know anymore and then you watch
it on snl or someone else on like
another political kind of uh comedy talk
show
and they're just
pulling the truth from what was
literally said
and maybe exaggerating a little bit you
know like the flying pence's head was
ended up being joe biden
on his head
and herman cain was on there right but
it's like those are real things that are
being made fun of from real events
and uh it's also funny just see that
whole the right or the base look at it
and be like
and reject it to be
that never happened that was never said
that was an exaggeration that was a joke
you know that's that's not what he meant
and it's like
how
like what world what reality do you live
in that you are unable to just like
you're able to watch it but not able to
really
see
or accept it you know
well and a good example is i know you
posted and i think i had it on
a twitch stream that i did the other day
where you posted a video
uh because donald trump put out this big
statement that their new slogan is make
america great again again again and
again and again and maybe again maybe
again but probably never right probably
never again but right but you actually
you found this clip from it was the 2020
campaign right
yeah he was in i think it was new
hampshire it was october 2020 and he
sees a guy in the crowd
and he's like uh yeah you got that you
know make america great again hat and
he's like i'm gonna throw it i'm gonna
throw another again on there it's gonna
make america great again again
and it sounds ridiculous because even
even the slogan itself like that slogan
he stole from ronald reagan during the
1980 campaign which was like let's make
america great again
and then you know classic trump he just
goes
i'll just take someone else's thing and
and and uh and take credit for it and so
it was let's make america great again to
make america great again and he has
the
he's like unable to have an original
thought so he goes well you know what
make america great again worked so we
throw on comma again
and in the video he says that he jokes
about it and everyone's like oh cheering
you know and they laugh about it and he
literally says
i'm going to throw another again on
there so i can
sell you another hat
and i know that was one of the biggest
things that they they talked about
during the campaign they're like oh we
sold over a million you know make
america great again hats
and it's all a grip and they're
literally there and they're like oh he's
laughing he's he must be joking okay
that's funny we'll all laugh but he's
like no he literally told you his intent
and then he did it
and you're gonna buy it up and you're
gonna eat it you know why i mean i think
that's almost
the entire
from 2015 really when he announced all
the way up until now oh yeah it's
continued to be grift i mean i i and
i've said this several times on the
podcast and i i've tweeted out that we
are
we are at the intersection of
wrestlemania and real life here like
literally
the ivermectin store is on one corner
and the the [ __ ] rnc
cpac going going to
uh hungary is on the other corner like
what in the hell is happening like how
can you how can you even think to make
this [ __ ] up and that's really that's
the tough part for comedians like you
now i use a lot of comedy i'm more i
consider myself more of a commentator
who uses comedy but you are you are
writing this comedy and it must be
difficult to write the comedy speaking
speaking of grifters and writing comedy
and someone with the name
donald trump you have a video
uh with don jr in it and he's
looks like he's grifting in it because a
while back you know everyone's wondering
if these people are running out of money
which of course they they probably are
but don jr gets on cameo and he was
charging like
like 500 bucks or something i don't know
what he was changing he's still he still
is i think he's actually charging more
than that and like even more for like
the 24-hour turnaround kind of thing i
mean they're all on cameo as like how do
you make a quick buck to say
the most simple things like what maybe
maybe we should go on cameo i i have you
considered i i think maybe we should go
on cameo i could do i could just say
[ __ ] them
and into the you know [ __ ] them oh it's
your birthday [ __ ] them and i could you
know griff to be i don't know maybe
someone would pay me 20 30 bucks to do
that i don't know i doubt it but i i
just i find it funny that that it's not
just like him it's his entire universe
around him
that has gotten into this grift and i
think that's a lot of this ivormectin
facebook it's all one big huge
[ __ ] grift for someone to make money
somewhere
and if he gets part of it great if he
doesn't you know maybe his supporters
will so but i do want to play a grifter
video that you did a while back how do
you know how old this video is
it had to have been right when he did
the cameo so it's got to be from the
summer right
uh not too yeah yeah probably the last
couple months so this is this is this is
gabe's rendition of
a don junior cameo video so let's don jr
and uh this cameo goes out to a fellow
patriot by the name of uh
ima
lou
sir am i standing right there emers and
ima because i think it said i'm a
i'ma
sir
anyway just want to wish you i'm a happy
birthday and uh uh
you look great for
uh line
you look great for forty
eric get out of the trash i told you
that pizza has mold on it
line
this is the best part when he calls for
lime but it's not it's not what you
think it's it's exactly what you think
yeah
so so how do you because man i'm i'm
gonna be honest with you like the makeup
is spot-on or maybe it's not makeup how
much coke did you have to do or what did
you have to do to prepare to look like
don junior yeah i set up a whole another
business to just completely expense
those business items you know as
research if you will
do your own research right yeah um but
no it's the the makeup and i will say
like the the
the purpose or the goal of the videos is
like i want to create a world right like
how however ridiculous or outrageous
the scenario is that they're in
like i want to create some realness to
it and there are some people on you know
antique talk and twitter or whatever and
instagram that make videos and they're
just like
i'll put a like a little like a towel on
my head and i'll be the girl or like
i'll
go from the other angle and it's like oh
here's like a quick back and forth but
with my videos you know in and those
videos work they're totally fine uh but
for my style i i really want to create
that work and to do that
you know i put in design you know i'm a
designer so i'll put in design to link
different props like like you saw with
the ivermectin and
hydroxychloroquine and you know all the
different things like i'm putting time
in to like add those little details
because i feel like it enriches the the
video um especially for the viewer uh
and sometimes i'll like hide little
easter eggs in there and
um but they
they take some time like it's there's
the writing process and then there's the
whole like all right what what props am
i going to use in here and for like don
jr you know i'm putting on
uh
it's a combination of burning and the
secret here for anyone who wants to know
the secret is you're burning a cork
uh and then you're rubbing it on your
face to create that kind of that five
o'clock shadow that beard and then i'm
taking like flour for instance so i'm
like digging through my my girlfriend's
like flower staff just like
putting on my face
um that's the coke obviously that's the
coke right yeah yeah that is the because
you're not you're not using real cocaine
i mean it's not a you know you just
don't rock down the street to your
dealer okay well yeah
i mean
a lot of people ask me like how i get my
eyes so red and they're like either you
irritated them that much or you're
really on coke
uh but that is another prop that i do um
no like it's all these are all practical
effects there's no like
special effects in these videos um it's
putting stuff in my eyes
putting flour on my face
uh and on my jacket and everything
and again it's to sell
the idea that
um
this is that character in that scenario
and in this one it's it's don jr and
he's trying to make a quick buck by
selling a cameo and
can't quite you know
uh pick up on the joke that he's that
he's a part of
um
so yeah it's it's a process it takes
some time especially trying to figure
out like oh i've got this idea and then
how do i create that character
uh and what like
kind of tools or aid do i need to
to make it go forward
so so i i do notice that you put a lot
of time into your props in your videos
but one of my favorite props one of my
favorite props is the the trump hat um
obviously i'm wearing a red hat because
i want to make red hats wearable again
yeah
but you you
you have different renditions
of the of the hat and and there seems to
be like an evolution of this of the
manga hat inside your videos
and
to go back to the don junior because
there was one point i want to make and
then we'll get to the hats yeah was was
the script that the cameo that you would
have paid for was that the
yeah that's what i would have liked so
so you wanted the don jr video without
having to pay for it it's kind of the
yeah i got you okay good yeah i wanted
to figure out a way how to be like if i
were to make a video
you know how do i sneak in a word that
if he says it
at a certain cadence that it would
actually be a different
a different thing altogether it was
fantastic so